houas
oh
hello les rendus à la génération des
gens qui ont aucune connexion avec ceux
qui n'ont jamais été l'église sont pas
baptisés fax et des gens qui se posent
beaucoup de questions et qui sont
vraiment une grosse réflexion
spirituelle entre émergence un peu du
milieu chrétien puis je pense que
l'église actuelle temps de vraiment
s'adapter ou par exemple intègre acheter
quand on est beaucoup de jeunes donc
c'est comme si c'est vraiment un bon
moyen de se rejoindre sur facebook aussi
en un groupe facebook danser c'est quand
même bonne manière de de rejoindre les
jeunes je pense que c'est pour ça qu'on
aime beaucoup mais j'ai regardé les
sites de ces groupes dans goon bernier
puisqu'ils me frapper c'est à quel point
il avait saisi
la culture le bit le bide du plateau de
et du coeur de montréal foodie en tige
jeunes adultes et c'est rafraîchissant
parce que on peut pas dire que c'est
fréquent chez nous nous église plus
établis historiquement au québec de voir
ça on n'a pas commencé avec les dés de
dire voici le moyen de les attirer fait
que ce savoir-faire puis ça va être ça
va être notre note moyens de les faire
venir nous voir les gens de notre époque
dommages à la nation ce quartier il
s'est adressé à quelque chose de temps